E
BIG STORIES BEEN WITH US THE
LAST TWO YEARS IS COVID-19.
THE ORIGIN IS THE TOP STORY, BUT
THE FOCUS OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
ON VACCINATION IS MIND BOGGLING.
LISTEN, MANY CASES, THEY'VE DONE
A VERY GOOD JOB GETTING THE WORD
OUT AND GETTING THE VACCINE OUT
FROM JOHNSON & JOHNSON TO PFIZER
TO MODERNA, THEY ARE AVAILABLE
IF YOU WANT THEM BUT THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH.
NOW YOU NEED TO BE BERATED BY
NONE OTHER THAN DR. FAUCI
BECAUSE YOU'RE PLAYING POLITICS.
THAT'S THE REASON YOU MAY HAVE
NOT GOTTEN IT.
LISTEN.
>> THIS IS NOT COMPLICATED.
WE'RE NOT ASKING ANYBODY TO MAKE
ANY POLITICAL STATEMENT ONE WAY
OR  ANOTHER.
WE'RE SAYING TRY AND SAVE YOUR
LIFE AND THAT OF YOUR FAMILY,
AND THAT OF THE COMMUNITY.
HERE WE HAVE A VACCINE THAT'S
HIGHLY, HIGHLY EFFECTIVE.
IT'S EASY TO GET.
IT'S FREE, AND IT'S READILY
AVAILABLE SO YOU'VE GOT TO ASK
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM?
GET OVER IT.
GET OVER THIS POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
JUST GET OVER IT AND TRY AND
SAVE THE LIVES OF YOURSELF AND
YOUR FAMILY.
BRIAN:  PRESUMPTUOUS TO THINK
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE VACCINE
IF IT IS INDEED THE CASE BECAUSE
OF POLITICS.
MAYBE YOU HAD THE VIRUS ALREADY.
MAYBE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
ANTIBODIES.
MAYBE THE FACT IS EMERGENCY USE
DOESN'T MAKE YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
WHY NOT GIVE PEOPLE CREDIT
RATHER THAN TRYING TO BERATE
THEM INTO DOING SOMETHING
AND CLAIMING IT'S PLAYING
POLITICS.
AINSLEY: DOES YOUR DOCTOR TALK
TO YOU THAT WAY?
HE'S CLEARLY --
BRIAN:  GET OVER IT?
AINSLEY: YOU HAVE TO TAKE THIS
SHOT?
NO.
YOU TALK TO YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT
YOUR CHOICES AND YOU GET TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS.
WHAT IF YOU HAVE A 15-YEAR-OLD
AND WATCH FOX & FRIENDS WHEN
BRIAN INTERVIEWED THE DAD WHOSE
SON IT HURTS EVERY TIME HIS
HEARTBEATS HE TELLS HIS DAD
AFTER HE GOT THE SHOT.
HE CAN'T PLAY SOCCER ANYMORE AND
NO TELLING HOW LONG HE WILL DEAL
WITH THESE ISSUES.
I'M NOT SAYING DON'T GET YOUR
KIDS VACCINATED.
THAT'S YOUR CHOICE AS A PARENT
BUT YOU HAVE TO KNOW ALL OF THE
FACTS AND WHEN FAUCI SAYS
GET OVER IT WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THAT DAD, DR. FAUCI?
DO YOU TELL HIM TO GET OVER IT
HIS SON CAN'T PLAY SOCCER ANY
MORE?
PETE: GET OVER IT WE'RE SAVING
YOUR LIFE.
DOCTORS GIVE YOU RECOMMENDATIONS
AND INFORMATION.
IF I GO IN AND I'M MORBIDLY
OBESE AND HE SAYS STOP EATING SO
MUCH STEAK, PETE, I GET TO
CHOOSE WHAT MY NEXT MEAL LOOKS
LIKE.
SAME THING HERE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION,
YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR HEALTH
BACKGROUND IS, AGE, RESPONSIBLE
FOR YOUR KIDS, TO SHAME PEOPLE
TO GET A VACCINE IS NOT
EFFECTIVE AND IT WORRIES PEOPLE
THAT THAT WILL TURN EVENTUALLY
INTO A MANDATE WHEN THIS IS NO
LONGER EMERGENCY USE, WHEN
SCHOOLS ARE REOPENING, THAT'S
WHEN I THINK WE'LL HAVE A REAL
CROSSING.
BRIAN:  ARE THEY GOING TO
MANDATE SCHOOLS HAVE TO GET THE
SHOT AND HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO PROVE YOU GOT THE SHOT?
SO AND IF YOU DON'T GET THE SHOT
ARE YOU TOLD TO GET OFF CAMPUS?
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW
THAT GOES, BUT DR. JEANETTE NESH
WAT TALKED US
TO EARLIER ABOUT THE PATIENTS
SHE'S SEEN AND THE REASONS THEY
DON'T GET THE VACCINE.
>> WHEN I ASK MY PATIENTS
KINDLY AND RESPECT FULLY WHY
THEY AREN'T VACCINATED, THE
SMALL PERCENTAGE THAT ARE
NOT THEY NEVER TELL ME I DON'T
KNOW WHERE TO GO.
WHAT I HEAR IS THEY JUST HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE DUE TO WORK
SCHEDULE OR  FAMILY SCHEDULE.
ALSO, SOME OF THEM STILL HAVE A
LOT OF UNANSWERED QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
I TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
ANSWER AND ADDRESS THOSE
QUESTIONS, AND A VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE ARE JUST NOT
READY AND DON'T WANT THE VACCINE
, SO AGAIN, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION, PROVIDE THAT
EDUCATION, AND LET THEM MAKE
THAT DECISION THAT'S BEST FOR
THEM.
PETE: PERSONAL CHOICE.
I BELIEVE, YOU KNOW, I'M FINE
WITH LEADERS SAYING PLEASE,
PLEASE, THAT'S FINE.
I'LL MAKE THE CHOICE THEN AS A
RESULT.
YOU'VE GIVEN ME THE INFORMATION
AND THAT'S REINFORCEMENT.
AINSLEY: THEY KNOW WHERE TO GET
THE VACCINE.
EVERY DRUG STORE OR  GROCERY
STORE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
BRIAN:  THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT.
AINSLEY: WE HAVE ALL OF THESE
POP-UP DOCTORS, SMALL LITTLE ON
EVERY CORNER.
YOU KNOW WHERE TO GET A VACCINE
IF YOU DON'T YOU COULD EASILY
ASK YOUR FRIEND WHO GOT A
VACCINE WHERE DO I GO?
BRIAN:  PLUS THEY ARE KNOCKING
ON YOUR DOOR SOON SO GO HOME AND
CHECK YOUR RING DOOR BELL, DR.
FAUCI MIGHT BE THERE NEXT
MONTH, AND A COTTON BALL.
WE'LL SEE HOW THAT GOES, HAVE
YOUR DELTOID READY TO GO.
PETE: YOU ALWAYS DO.
BRIAN:  OR  WHEN YOU'RE NOT ON
THE SHOW, NO SLEEVES.
PETE: MOST OF THE TIME AT HOME
I'M WEARING A TANK TOP.
AINSLEY: YOU'RE A TANK TOP KIND
OF GUY.
ARE YOU?
PETE: I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THAT
CHARACTERIZATION.
AINSLEY: YOU COULD PULL IT OFF.
JILLIAN AND I HAD THIS
CONVERSATION ONE-TIME.
WE'RE NOT INTO THE TANK TOPS ON
GUYS, BUT, IF YOU HAVE THEM IT'S
OKAY.
PETE: WHAT IF IT'S A BASKETBALL
JERSEY